how y'all sure I'm really guy you could
join us yesterday I'm very glad to you
know
today you're not just saved researcher
or engineer in deep learning you've
become one of the institution's and one
of the icons of deep learning but really
like to hear the story of how it started
so how did you end up you know getting
into deep learning and then pursuing
this journey right well actually it
started when I was a kid
adolescent reading a lot of science
fiction like I guess many of us and when
I started my graduate studies in 1985 I
started reading you know led papers and
and that's where I got all excited and
it became really a passion and and
actually what was that like in what mid
eighties right 1985 reading these papers
do you remember yeah it was well you
know coming from the courses I had taken
in classical ai with expert systems and
suddenly discovering that there was all
this world of thinking about how humans
might be learning and human intelligence
and how we might draw connections
between that and and artificial
intelligence and computers that was
really exciting for me when I discovered
this literature and I started reading
the connectionists of course so the
papers from geoff hinton real art and so
on and I worked on recurrent Nets I
worked on speech recognition I worked on
hmmso graphical models and then quickly
moved to AT&T Bell Labs and MIT where I
did postdocs and that's where I
discovered some of the issues with the
long term dependencies with training
neural nets and then shortly after I got
recruited
udm back in Montreal where I had spent
most of my child I know lessons years um
you know and so as someone who's been
there for the last several decades and
seen you know seeing it also he's seen a
lot of it
um tell me about how you're thinking
about deep learning about neural
networks has evolved over this over this
time we start with experiments with
intuitions and and theory sort of comes
later and we now understand a lot better
for example why backdrop is working so
well why depth is so important and and
you know these kinds of notions we we
didn't have any solid justification for
in those days when when we started
working on deep nets in the early 2000s
we had the intuition that we made a lot
of sense that a deeper network should be
more powerful and we didn't know how to
you know take that and prove it and of
course our experiments initially didn't
work and actually well there were the
most important things that you think
turned out to be right and what were the
biggest surprises of what turns out to
be wrong you know compared to what we
knew thirty years ago
oh sure so one of the biggest mistake I
made was to think that like everyone
else in the 90s thought you needed
smooth nonlinearities in order to for
backprop to work because I thought that
you know if if we had something like
rectifying non-linearity's where you
have a flat part that it would be really
hard to train because the derivative
would be zero in so many places and when
we started experimented with
experimenting with relu with deepness in
around 2010 you know III was obsessed
with the idea that oh we should be
careful about whether neurons won't
saturate too much on the zero part but
in the end it turned out that actually
the relu was working a lot better than
the sigmoids and attached and that was a
big surprise we did this exploring this
because of the biological connection
actually not because we thought that it
would be easier to optimize but it
turned out work better
whereas I thought it would be harder to
drink so let me ask you what is the
relationship between deep learning and
the brain there's the obvious answer but
I'm curious was your answer to that ah
well the initial insight that really got
me excited with neural nets was this
idea from the connectionists that
information is distributed across the
activation of many neurons rather than
being represented by and sort of the
grandmother cells that were calling it
were a symbolic representation that was
the traditional view in classical yet
right and I still believe this is a
really important thing and I see people
we just discovering the importance of
that even even though recently so so
that's that was really a foundation the
death thing is something that came later
in the thousands it wasn't something I
was thinking about it and I nice for
sure for example I remember you build a
lot of relatively shallow but very
disputed representations for the word
embeddings very very early on then
that's right yeah that's that's one of
the things that I got really excited
about in the late 90s was actually my
brother Sonny and I worked on the idea
that we could use neon Nets to tackle
the curse of dimensionality which was
believed to be one of the central issues
with statistical learning and the fact
that we could have these representations
could be used to represent joint
distributions over many random variables
in a very efficient way and it turned
out to work quite well and then I
extended this to joint solutions over
sequences of words and this is how the
word embeddings were born because I
thought oh you know this will allow
analyzation across words that have
similar semantic meaning and Poussin
so over the last you know a couple
decades your research group has invented
more ideas than anyone can summarize in
a few minutes sound Chris what are the
inventions or ideas yeongho's proud of
from your group
right so I think I mentioned long-term
dependencies the study of that I think
people still don't understand it well
enough then there's the story I
mentioned about curse with emission
allottee joint distributions with neural
nets which which became more recently
the the nadir that's Hugo's and Rochelle
did and then as I said that gave rise to
also the work on learning word
embeddings for joint distributions for
words then came I think probably the the
best-known events of the work we did
with deep learning with stacks of old
encoders and stacks of RPMs one thing
then it was the work on understanding
better the difficulties of training deep
nets with exactly Laura with the
initialization ideas and also the
vanishing gradient in in deep nets and
that work actually was the one which
gave rise to the experiments showing the
importance of piecewise linear
activation functions then I would say
some of the most important work regards
to work we did with unsupervised
learning the denoising auto-encoders the
gans which are very popular these days
the narrative adversarial Awards the
work we did with neural machine
translation using attention which turned
out to be really important for making
attention making translation work and is
currently used in industrial systems
like Google Translate but this attention
thing actually really changed my views
nets you know knew immense we used to
think as machines that can map a vector
to a vector but but really with
attention mechanisms you can now handle
any kind of data structure and this is
this is really opening up interesting
avenues direction of actually connecting
to biology one thing that I've been
working on in the last couple of years
is how could we come up with something
like backprop but that brains could
implement and we have a few papers in
that direction that seems to be
interesting for the
signs people and then we're continuing
in that direction of course one of the
topics that I know you've been thinking
all about is the relationship between
deep learning and the brain can you tell
us a bit more about that the biological
thing is something I've been thinking
about for fara well actually and and and
and having a lot of I would say they
dreamin about because it's it's like I
think a bit like a puzzle so we have
these pieces of evidence from what we
know from the brain and from learning in
the brain like spike timing-dependent
plasticity and and on the other hand we
have all these concepts from machine
learning the idea of globally training
the whole system with respect to an
objective function and the idea of
backprop and i know and what does
backprop mean like what does credit
assignment really mean when I started
thinking about how brains could do
something like back profits it you know
prompted me to think about well maybe
there's like some more general concepts
behind back prop which make it so
efficient which allow us to to be
efficient with backdrop maybe there's a
larger family of ways to the credit
assignment and that connects to
questions that people in reinforcement
learning have been asking so it's
interesting how sometimes asking a
simple question leads you to thinking
about so many different things and and
forces you to think about so many
elements that you'd like to bring
together like a big puzzle so this has
gone for a number of years I need to say
that this whole endeavor like many of
the ones that have followed has been
highly inspired by Jeff Hinton's
thoughts so in particular he gave this
talk in 2007 I think the first deep
learning workshop on what he thought was
the way that the brain is working how
temporal
kind of temporal code could be used for
potentially to make some of the job of
not prob and and that you know led to a
lot of the ideas that I've explored in
recent years with this yeah so it's kind
of an interesting story that has been
running for a decade now basically one
of the topics I've heard you speak about
multiple times as well is unsupervised
learning yeah can you share your
perspective on that yes yes
so unsupervised learning is really
important right now
our industrial systems are based on
supervised learning which essentially
requires humans to define what the
important concepts are for the problem
and to label those concepts and the data
and you know we build all these amazing
toys and services and systems using this
but humans are able to do much more they
are able to explore and discover new
concepts by observation and interaction
with the world a two-year-old is able to
understand intuitive physics in other
words she understands gravity she
understands pressure he understands
inertia
she understands liquid solids and of
course her parents never told her about
any of these stuff right so how did you
figure it out so that's the kind of
question that unsupervised learning is
trying to answer it's not just about we
have labels or we don't have labels it's
about actually building a construction a
mental construction that explains how
the world works by by observation and
more recently I've been combining the
ideas and as premised learning with the
ideas and reinforcement learning because
I believe that there's a very strong
indication about the important
underlying concepts that we're trying to
disentangle we're trying to separate
from each other that a human or machine
can get by interacting with the book by
by exploring the world and trying things
and trying to control things
so these these are I think tightly
coupled to the original ideas of
premised wedding so my take on lands
provides learning 15 years ago when we
started doing the auto encoder
Cynthia rpms and so on was very focused
on the idea of learning good
representations and I still think this
is a central question but the the thing
we don't know is how and what is a good
representation how do we figure out a an
objective function for example so we've
tried many things over the years and
that's actually one of the cool things
about its provides learning research
that there are so many different ideas
different ways that this problem can be
attacked and then that's just maybe
there's another one we'll discover you
know next year that's completely
different and and and maybe the brain is
using something else completely
different so it's it's not incremental
research it's something that in itself
is very exploratory we don't have like a
good definition of what's the right
objective function to even measure that
a system is doing a good job on its
points learning so of course it's
challenging but at the same time there's
you know it leaves open why and feel
full of possibilities which is what you
know researchers really love at least
that's something that appeals to me so
you know today there's so much going on
in deep learning and I think we've
passed the point where it's possible for
any one human to read every single deep
learning paper being published so I'm
curious what a deep journey today
excites you then though huh so I'm I'm
very ambitious and I feel like the
current state of science of deep
learning is far from anything we're
applying it to see it and I have the
impression that our systems right now
make mistakes that suggests the kind of
mistakes that suggest that they have a
very superficial understanding of the
world so what excites me the most now is
sort of direction of research where
we're not trying to build systems I'm
gonna do something useful we're just
going back to principles about how can a
computer
observe the world interact with the
world and discover how that world works
even if that world is simple something
that we can program is a kind of video
game we don't know how to do that well
and that's cool because I don't have to
compete with Google and Facebook and
Baidu and so on right because this is a
kind of basic research that can be done
by anyone in their Garret and could
change the world
so there are many of course many
directions to attack this but I see a
lot of the fruitful interactions between
ideas and deep learning and
reinforcement learning being really
important there and you know I'm really
excited that the progress in this
direction could have a huge impact on
practical applications actually because
if you look at some of the big
challenges that we have in applications
like how we deal with new domains or
categories on which we have too few
examples and in cases where humans are
very good at solving those problems so
these transfer learning and joys Asian
issues they would become much easier to
tackle if we have systems that had a
better understanding of how the world
works a deeper understanding right what
is actually going on what are the causes
of what I'm seeing and and how could I
you know influence what I'm saying by my
actions so these these are the kinds of
questions and really excited about these
days and I think they connect also the
deep learning research that has evolved
for the last couple of decades with even
all the questions in the eye because a
lot of the sisters success in deep
learning has been with perception so
what's left right what's left is sort of
high-level cognition which is about
understanding at an abstract level how
things work so we our program of
understanding high-level abstractions I
think has you know not reached those
high levels of abstractions and so we
have to get there we have to think about
reasoning about sequential processing of
information we have to think of how
causality works and and how machines can
discover all these things by themselves
essentially guided by humans but as much
as possible in an autonomous way and it
sounds like from I love what you said
that you're a fan of research approaches
where you experiment on you know I'm
going to use the term toy problem not in
the disparaging right but on the small
problem and you're optimistic that that
transfers to bigger problems later yes
yes yes and I mean it transfers in in a
meta way right of course we're gonna
have to do some work to escape a lab and
address those problems but my main
motivation for going for those toy
problems is that we can understand
better our failures and we can reduce
use the problem to something we can
intuitively sort of manipulate and
understand more easily so sort of
classical divide and conquer you know
science approach and also I think
something people don't think about
enough is the cycle the research cycle
can be much faster right so if I can do
an experiment in in a few hours
I can I can progress much faster if if I
have to try a huge model that's trying
to capture the whole common sense and
you know everything in the general
knowledge which will eventually we'll do
is just that each experiment just takes
too much time with current hardware
so while of our hardware friends are
building machines they're gonna be a
thousand or million times faster I'm
doing those toy experiments you know I
shall also just speak about the signs of
deep learning it's not just as a
engineering discipline but doing more
work to understand what's really going
on
do you share your thoughts on that you
know absolutely I fear that a lot of the
work that they're doing is sort of like
blind people trying to find their way
and you know you can get a lot of luck
and and find interesting things that way
but but really if we sort of stop a
little bit and I'm trying to understand
what we're doing in in a way that's
transferable because because we go down
to
spools to theory but when I say theory I
don't need necessarily math I don't I'm
not like of course I like math and so on
but but I don't think that we need that
everything be formalized mathematically
but be formalized logically in other
sense that I can convince somebody that
you know this should work with it this
makes sense this is the most important
aspect and then math you know allows us
to make that stronger and tighter but
but really it's more about understanding
and it's about also doing our research
not to beat the next space line or
benchmark or you know beat the other
guys in the other lab or the other
company it's more about you know what
kind of question should we ask that will
allow us to understand better the
phenomena of interest like you know what
makes for example training in deeper
networks harder or any current nets
harder we have some ideas but a lot of
things we don't understand yet so we can
maybe design experiments whose goal is
not to have like a better all of them
but just to understand better the
algorithms we currently have or you know
why what circumstances make particular
algorithm work better and then why I
mean it's the Y that really matters
that's what science is about it's why
right today there are a lot of people
that want to enter the fuse and I'm sure
you've answered there's a lot in
one-on-one settings but you know with
all the people watching this on video
what advice would you have for people
that want to get into AR again there's a
deep learning and so so first of all
there are different motivations that
different things you could do you know
what you need to become a deep learning
researcher may not be the same as if you
want to be an engineer who's going to
use deep learning to build products
there's a different level of
understanding that's needed in both
cases but but in any case in both cases
practice practice so to really master a
subject like deep learning you of course
you have to read a lot you have to
practice so programming the things
yourself
very often I
you know I interview students who have
used software and these days there's so
somebody knows so good software around
that you can just you know plug and play
and understand nothing of what you're
doing or it's such a superficial level
that then it becomes hard to figure out
when it doesn't work and what's going
wrong so actually trying to implement
things yourself even if it's inefficient
but just to make sure you really
understand what is going on is really
useful and and you know 20 No so that
don't just use one of the program
framework so you can do everything in a
few lines of code but you don't really
know what what just happen right exactly
exactly and and I would say even more
than that trying to derive the thing
yourself from you know first principles
if you can so that really helps but you
know I mean the usual things you have to
do like reading looking at other
people's code writing your own code
doing a lot of experiment making sure
you understand everything you do so I
mean especially for the science part of
it trying to ask why am I doing this why
are people doing this and maybe the
answer is is somewhere in the book and
you have to read more but it's even
better if you can actually figure it out
by yourself and and in fact of the
things I read you and you know fellow
erinkoval wrote a highly very highly
regarded book thank you thank you
yes it's selling a lot it's a bit crazy
I feel like there's more people reading
this book than people who can read it
right now but but yeah also Proceedings
of the IEEE CLR iclear conference is
probably the best concentrated place of
good papers of course they're really
good papers at nips and ICML and other
conferences but but if you really want
to go for a lot of good papers just with
the last few I see a lot of proceedings
and that will give you a really good
view of the field any other thoughts
that when people ask you for advice you
know how does someone write become good
at deep learning well
it depends on where you come from don't
be afraid by the math just you know just
develop the intuitions and then the math
become really easier to understand once
once you get the hang of what's going on
at the intuitive level and one good news
is that you don't need five years of PhD
to become proficient at deep planning
you can actually learn pretty quickly if
you have a a good background in computer
science and math you can you can learn
enough to use it and build things and
and start research experiments in just a
few months you know something like six
months for people with the right
training may maybe they don't know
anything about machine learning but if
they're good in math and computer
science it can be very fast and of
course so that means you need to have
the right training in math computer
science sometimes what you would you
learn in in just computer science
courses is not enough you need some some
you know continuous path especially so
that this is the improbability algebra
and optimization for example and
calculus in calculus yeah thanks a lot
you're sure for sharing all the comments
and insights and advice even though I've
learned even though I've known you for a
long time there are many details of your
early history that I didn't know until
now so thank you well thank you Andrew
for doing this this special recording
and what you're doing and well I hope
it's going to be used by a lot of people